&gt;&gt; Because functions are so unique and have an input and output, we have another
way of representing it. Instead of using y, we'll use something else. We'll use
f of x, or a function of x because the output relies on the input x. F of x is
the name of the function that represents the output. And x is our input
variable. And this side of the equation describes how we change x. To find the
value or output of a function, we use substitution. For example, we could
evaluate this function for x equals 3. My input is 3, so I plug it in. I want to
find the output, or f of 3, by carrying out this math. So, here, the output,
when x is 3, is 7. When you see a statement like this, you really want to think
of it in terms of the outputs and inputs. When the input x is equal to 3, the
output of the function or the y value is 7. We don't have to evaluate our
function for just numbers though. We could also use another expression. For
example, if my input x was 3 x squared, I would plug it into my function. So,
the output of 3 x squared would be 6 x squared plus 1. This would be the answer
containing a variable. Notice, it's not just a number.